PETE: JILLIAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW LET’S BRING IN SOMEONE
WHO WAS THERE LAST NIGHT GEORGIA
GOP CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS
CONGRESSMAN THANKS FOR BEING
HERE THIS MORNING.
THE PRESIDENT WAS IN FAMILIAR
FORM LAST NIGHT.
WE GOT YOU ALMOST TAKE FOR
GRANTED HOW OFTEN HE DID
RALLIES LIKE THIS I BELIEVE THIS
WAS HIS FIRST POST-ELECTION
WHAT WAS IT LIKE TO BE THERE AND
SET THE STAKES OF THESE KEY
GEORGIA RACES.
>> WELL THANK YOU, PETE IT’S
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU ALL THIS
MORNING.
YEAH, THIS PRESIDENT IN HIS FORM
IS DOING THESE RALLIES AND LAST
NIGHT HE CAME TO GEORGIA AND
BROUGHT THE TRUTH OF THE FACT
THESE TWO SENATE RACES ARE SO
IMPORTANT IN THE FUTURE OF
AMERICA.
THIS IS NOT JUST NOW JUST TWO
SENATE RACES IN GEORGIA.
THIS IS ACTUALLY ABOUT CHANGING
THE DIRECTION OF THE UNITED
STATES SENATE AND PUTTING IT IN
THE HANDS OF CHUCK SCHUMER AND
AN AGENDA THAT IS SO RADICAL
LEFT THAT WE CANNOT ALLOW THIS
TO HAPPEN AND THE PRESIDENT
MADE IT VERY CLEAR LAST NIGHT,
IN EVERYTHING THAT’S GOING ON HE
SET THE STAGE AND SAID NO MATTER
WHAT YOU MAY FEEL ABOUT THE
ELECTION AND HOW THE
CONTROVERSIES HAVE BEEN
GOING ON HE MADE IT VERY CLEAR,
DAVID PERDUE AND KELLY LOEFFLER
NEED TO BE ELECTED BECAUSE JOHN
OSSOFF AND RAPHAEL WARNOCK
WOULD TAKE THIS COUNTRY DOWN A
PATH THAT’S TOO FAR EXTREME AND
LEFT AND HE WAS IN GOOD FORM
LAST NIGHT.
WILL: CONGRESSMAN THE PRESIDENT
WAS IN GOOD FORM WHEN IT CAME TO
YOU HE HAD VERY COMPLEMENTARY
THINGS TO SAY ABOUT YOU.
LET’S PLAY A CLIP AND THEN I’LL
ASK YOU A QUESTION.
WATCH THIS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: DOUG YOU WANT
TO RUN FOR GOVERNOR IN TWO YEARS
>> [APPLAUSE]
PRESIDENT TRUMP: A GOOD LOOKING
GOVERNOR.
WILL: CONGRESSMAN LET ME ASK YOU
, A POINTED BUT ALSO A BROAD
QUESTION AS WELL.
THE POINTED QUESTION IS DO YOU
WANT TO RUN FOR GOVERNOR IN TWO
YEARS BUT THE BROADER QUESTION
IS THIS.
WHAT SHOULD GEORGIANS MAKE OF TO
SOME EXTENT, SOME MESSAGES THAT
CAN SEEM CONFLICTING.
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE’S SOME
DOUBT OUT THERE ABOUT THE TRUST
IN THE SYSTEM THE VOTING SYSTEM
AND AS YOU CAN HEAR THERE SOME
FRUSTRATION WITH GOVERNOR BRIAN
KEMP, THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AS WELL BUT ALSO
RECOGNITION OF HOW IMPORTANT
THESE TWO SENATORIAL RACES ARE,
SO, THE BROAD QUESTION IS WHAT
SHOULD GEORGIANS THINK ABOUT THE
ENTIRE STATE OF THESE
MESSAGES AND WHAT THEY SHOULD BE
DOING AND POINTEDLY, ARE YOU
INTERESTED IN RUN R FOG GOVERNOR
>> I APPRECIATE THE PRESIDENT
HE’S A GOOD FRIEND THE ONLY
POLITICAL DECISION I’M LOOKING
AT RIGHT NOW IS HELPING DAVID
PERDUE AND KELLY LOEFFLER GET
ELECTED AND I DON’T THINK
THERE’S TWO MESSAGES HERE AND
TWO CONFLICTING MESSAGES.
IT’S AN  ANOMALY TO ACTUALLY SAY
THAT YOU HAVE TO DECIDE AND MAKE
SURE THAT OUR ELECTIONS HAVE THE
INTEGRITY THEY NEED THAT
EVERYBODY SHOW UP AND EVERYBODY
VOTE AND AT THE SAME TIME, MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY DOES SHOW UP
AND VOTE FOR KELLY LOEFFLER AND
DAVID PERDUE.
THOSE ARE NOT CONFLICTING
MESSAGES.
THOSE ARE HONEST MESSAGES.
REMEMBER WE’VE JUST I JUST DEALT
WITH FOUR YEARS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT TO
THIS DAY STILL NEVER RECOGNIZED
DONALD TRUMP AS THE PRESIDENT.
THE HASHTAG NOTMYPRESIDENT, ALL
OF THE INVESTIGATIONS, AND THIS
PRESIDENT WAS NEVER
ACCEPTED AND THE ELECTION WAS
NEVER ACCEPTED A FEW YEARS AGO.
WHY DON’T WE ALLOW A LITTLE BIT
OF TIME TO GO THROUGH WHERE THE
PRESIDENT CAN HAVE HIS LEGAL
CHALLENGES AND MAKE SURE THE
ELECTIONS ARE SAFE, SECURE,
AND EVERY LEGAL VOTE IS COUNTED
ESPECIALLY HERE IN GEORGIA, AS
WE HAVE TWO ELECTION RACES
COMING UP FOR KELLY LOEFFLER AND
DAVID PERDUE BUT AGAIN, I THINK
THE PRESIDENT JUST MAKING THE
CLEAR POINT THAT WE CAN DO
MORE THAN ONE THING AT A TIME.
WE CAN MAKE SURE OUR ELECTIONS
ARE SAFE WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
ENSURING THE SENATE DOES NOT GO
TO THE RADICAL LEFT.
JEDEDIAH: CONGRESSMAN, LET’S
TALK COVID-19 RELIEF.
A LOT OF BUSINESSES AROUND THE
COUNTRY GETTING INCREASINGLY
CONCERNED, INCREASINGLY
DESPERATE FOR THAT RELIEF.
NANCY PELOSI NOW COMING OUT
SAYING THAT SHE’S OKAY WITH A
SMALLER BILL, THE TIMING OF THAT
OBVIOUSLY TERRIBLY INTERESTING
AND HIGHLY POLITICAL.
BERNIE SANDERS NOW SAYING THOUGH
A NEW $900 BILLION BIPARTISAN
WORKERS TELLS ME THAT THIS IS
NOT A BILL THAT SHOULD BE PASSED
JEDEDIAH: SO THE TRUTH IS HERE
THAT WHILE POLITICIANS ARE
ARGUING ABOUT IT, PEOPLE ARE
JUST OUT THERE NEEDING HELP.
WHERE DOES THIS LAND, WHEN DOES
THE HELP ARRIVE?
>> WELL THAT’S A GREAT QUESTION
, BUT YOU KNOW, LOOK.
THERE WILL BE NO BILL ACCEPTABLE
TO BERNIE SANDERS, IF IT WASN’T
A GOVERNMENT TAKEOVER OF OUR
ECONOMY SO LET’S JUST BE HONEST
ABOUT THAT AND PUT HIM TO THE
SIDE AND THEN LOOK IN THE
DICTIONARY OF POLITICAL
HYPOCRISY BE NANCY PELOSI, THE
SPEAKER WHO ALL THROUGH THE
FALL WOULD NEVER COME TO THE
TABLE AND DISCUSS GETTING RELIEF
BEFORE THE ELECTION, AND THEN
MIRACULOUSLY NOW THAT SHE
BELIEVES JOE BIDEN WON THE
ELECTION AND VACCINE IS
AROUND THE CORNER OKAY I’LL
LOOK AT SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
THAT IS DESPICABLE.
WHAT THE SPEAKER SAID THE OTHER
DAY IN NOT PLAYING POLITICS AND
NOW PLAYING POLITICS, THERE ARE
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO ARE HURTING
RIGHT NOW.
WE WANTED TO SEE RELIEF, TARGET
OUR BUSINESSES AND THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED THIS
HELP AND THE PRESIDENT LAST
NIGHT SPOKE ABOUT THIS IN THE
RALLY WHEN HE SAID HE WANTS
TO SEE THIS RELIEF HAPPEN.
SPEAKER PELOSI SHOULD BE ASHAMED
OF HERSELF FOR ACTUALLY NOW
SHOWING WHAT WE’VE KNOWN ALL
ALONG AND THAT IS THAT THIS IS A
POLITICAL DECISION FOR HER, THAT
SHE’S BEEN SAYING THE ONLY THING
I GET FROM SPEAKER PELOSI IS NOW
SHE JUST ADMITTED WHAT WE’VE
KNOWN ALL ALONG.
SHE PLAYED POLITICS WITH PEOPLE
’S LIVES ON COVID RESPONSE
PETE: ABSOLUTELY SHE SAID IT
COULDN’T BE LOWER THAN
$2 TRILLION AND NOW HERE WE ARE
AT 900 BILLION AND IT MAKES NO
SENSE OTHER THAN THROUGH A
POLITICAL LENS.
CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS COME
BACK AFTER THE SPECIAL
ELECTION AND WE’LL ASK YOU THE
SAME QUESTION AND FORCE YOU
TO ACTUALLY ANSWER IT ABOUT
WHETHER YOU WANT TO RUN FOR
GOVERNOR.
>> [LAUGHTER]